الى التطورات في اوكرانيا فقد بدا وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي زياره لكياف واكد في
مستهل زيارته التي لم يعلن عنها مسبقا ان
بلاده تريد ضمانه ان تكون اوكرانيا قادره
على ردع خصومها على المدى البعيد وليس
مجرد النجاح في هجومها المضاد في المقابل
قال الكريملين ان دعم الامريكي المقدم
لكياف لن يغير نتيجه ما سماها العمليه
الروسيه الخاصه في اوكرانيا مزيد من
التفاصيل مع مراسلينا في اكياف ايهاب
العقدي وفي موسكو نور الدين دغير ايهاب
اطلعنا على ابرز جدول زياره
طبعا بلنكن يلتقى وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
بحث معه في تطورات السياسيه المرتبطه
بالحرب التي شنتها روسيا على اوكرانيا
اراد المسؤول الامريكي تاكيدا موقف واشنطن
الداعم والمستمر
لناحيه دعم اوكرانيا في موقفها واستمرار
المعارك لتحرير اراضيها المحتله
بلنكن اراد تثبيت استمرار الدعم العسكري
البعيد الامد لاوكرانيا وقال ان عمليه
تحرير الاراضي واختراق الدفاعات الارضيه
التي قامت بها روسيا في مناطق زفروجيا هي
عمليا عمليات نشطه وقد حققت اوكرانيا
تقدما فيها السلطات الاوكرانيه من جانبها
تريد التاكيد على اهميه استمرار الدعم
الامريكي لضخ المساعدات العسكريه الحربيه
باتجاه ارض خصوصا وان اوكرانيا تتوقع دعما
قريب الامد بدبابات
وزجها في المعارك في غضون ايام وان الدفع
الاولى من الدبابات البالغه الدبابات ستصل
الارض المعركه في القريب العاجل بعد انها
نحو 200 جندي اوكراني تدريباتهم على هذه
الدبابات ايضا اوكرانيا تريد تثبيت موقفها
بانها مستمره في عملياتها العسكريه بغض
النظر عن اي تطورات سياسيه ان كان من
الجانب الروسي او من الجانب الاوروبي وهي
ترغب بان يستمر الدعم الامريكي لموقفها في
هذه المرحله من الحرب التي تعتبر انها
وصلت الى مرحله مفصليه
قال انه ذهب الى اوكرانيا بطلب من الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن وان الولايات المتحده
تقف الى جانب
في موقفها نستمع الى ابرز ما جاء بتصريحات
الوزير الامريكي
انا هنا بطلب من الرئيس بايدن لاؤكد
التزامنا بالوقوف الى جانبكم للتاكد من
نجاحكم عسكريا في صد العدوان وليؤكد
وقوفنا الى جانبكم للتاكد من قدرتكم على
بناء اقتصاد قوي وديمقراطيه قويه لنصل الى
اوكرانيا التي تنتصر وستنتصر وستزدهر ايضا
وسنكون شركائها في هذه الجهود مع كثير من
دول العالم
نور الدين في موسكو اكياس تعتبر بان هذه
الزيارات من هذا النوع تزعج موسكو كيف
تراها ويراها الكريم
يبدو ان الجانب الروسي هنا يرد بشكل عسكري
وعملي حسب ما تصدره وزاره الدفاع وكذلك ما
تتحدث عنه رئاسه الكرملين اذا ما اردنا ان
نتحدث عن سياق الزياره التي تقرا هنا في
روسيا بانها جاءت بناء على مجموعه من
المعلومات التي تتحدث بها اوكرانيا على ان
هناك تقدما اوكرانيا على مستوى المساحات
في
وخاصه في رابوتينو وفيرب هنا اليوم
بالتحديد وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تحدثت بشكل
واضح ربما قد يكون هو البيان الاول الذي
تحدث فيه بشكل واضح عن طبيعه العمليات في
هذه المنطقه هناك موقف واضح اليوم صدر قبل
قليل من وزاره الدفاع تقول بشكل صريح بانه
لم يحدث اي تغيير على مستوى موقع القوات
الاوكرانيه في القوات الروسيه فيروجيا وان
المواجهات العسكريه لا تزال قائمه كما
كانت في السابق عند محيط
وكذلك بلده الرابوتينو وان القوات الروسيه
بكل تاكي تعمل على صد هذه الهجمات هناك
دفع قوي من القوات الاوكرانيه من اجل
احلال احداث خرق في هذه المساحه لكن لحد
الساعه الان وزاره الدفاع تتحدث بشكل واضح
لتقول ليس هناك اي تغيير على مستوى الموقع
والمواقع العسكريه
للجانب الروسي وان القوات الروسيه لا تزال
في مواقفها بكل تاكيد هي رساله قد تبدو
واضحه هنا من وزاره الدفاع ترسلها كاشاره
للجانب الامريكي ولجانب الغربي باعتبار
انها ترى روسيا بانهم الداعمين الاساسيين
للجانب الاوكراني عبر العتاد وعبر الاسلحه
بان اي دعم جديد للجانب الاوكراني ربما لن
يغير كذلك في المساحات كان هناك دعم تقول
روسيا خلال المراحل السابقه وخاصه عند
انطلاق ما اصطلح عليه بالهجوم المضاد
للقوات الاوكرانيه والذي يدخل شهره الثالث
وزير الدفاع شويغو قال بشكل واضح بان هذا
الهجوم لحد الساعه لم يحقق اي تقدم واي
نتيجه تذكر بالنسبه للجانب الاوكراني على
المستوى الع القوات اوكرانيا القوات
الروسيه لا تزال في مواقع اذا ماذا يعني
ان ياتي بلينك القراءه للجانب الروسي شكرا
هذا تعني تصريحات بلينكل بانها سيكون هناك
دعم مستمر للجانب الاوكراني هنا بشكل واضح
تحدث بان اي دعم واستمرار في الدعم يعني
انه دعوه للاستمرار في الحرب وان تقاتل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في اوكرانيا
الى اخر جنديين اوكراني وبان ذلك لن يغير
في المساحات وان رقعه الحرب لن تتغير
باعتبار ان روسيا ربما قد تغير في
استراتيجياتها العسكريه من اجل ابقاء على
مساحته وربما التقدم نحو مساحات اخرى وهو
ما يمكن ان يقرا ويشاهد عسكريا خاصه في
مناطق الجبهات الشماليه والشماليه الغربيه
وبعد مناطق الجبهات الوسطى شكرا لكم نور
الدين في موسكو وايهاب